Here's our basic programmable pipeline, with a vertex shader and a fragment
shader. Once upon a time both these stages were not programmable. They were
handled by what was called the Fixed Function Pipeline. Transistors in the GPU
were specifically dedicated to the Transform and Rasterization processes. The
programmer basically set a bunch of switches and values that controlled the
flow of data. However, there's no real programmability involved. The Nintendo
Wii was about the last to use this type of architecture. In 2002, GPUs started
to appear that included vertex and fragment shaders. A shader is truly a
programmable piece of the pipeline. In other words, you actually send little,
or sometimes large, shader programs to each of these units. These programs are
written in a C-like language, if you know what C or C++ looks like. Up to this
point, we've been having Three.js do the programming for us. When we create a
material, Three.js actually creates two small programs, one each for the vertex
and fragment shaders. When the object with that material is to be displayed,
these shaders are loaded with their programs. The triangles are then sent down
the pipeline, and the programs are executed.